each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
we get started welcome to the second
morning session cloud computing and
chemistry and our first speaker this
morning is Mark borkum from University
of Southampton all right great thanks
can everyone hear me before I start
perfect the hecklers already great okay
so I'm here to talk about the re chem
project as the title says planning an
enacting chemistry on the Semantic Web
so just to give a quick overview of
presentation we start off with a brief
introduction then I'll talk you through
the re chem ontology do a quick case
study for x-ray crystallography and then
talk about the future work that we have
planned for the project so what is
aricam all about it's about the
scientific method so the little SmartArt
graphic that I've got on the screen
gives a summary of the scientific method
from my perspective probably worth
noting that i'm on the computer
scientist I cohabitate with the chemists
it's a an interesting arrangement but it
gives me a unique insight into the work
that they do and it's quite nice
actually to come after everything from a
different angle and different
perspective so the scientific method
from my perspective is all about
planning and enactment so planning you
formulate some kind of hypothesis or a
strategy for your work some people write
it down hopefully they put that in their
lab notebook then you enact said plan
you do some analysis on whatever results
you might have obtained during that
enactment and then you publish something
typically a paper at a conference and as
everyone's been talking about this is
becoming increasingly data intensive or
data extensive if you're Jeremy fray and
this is quite interesting how the cycle
is actually affecting research so what's
happening now is people will take other
people's data and formulate their own
new hypotheses and do new experiments
with that so it's just interesting where
people are entering this cycle nowadays
so there's a problem though and the
problem is the the data values so I like
to do these things in haiku if you can
summarize something in haiku then it's
typically pretty good so lots of
producers generating more data than ever
before just the example of that in x-ray
crystallography 40 years ago a PhD
student would generate three structures
over the course of their entire study
nowadays I know people who can generate
10 structures in a day so it's a more
than exponential growth in terms of what
people can do so this is the goal
everyone talks about so you want a kind
of graph of linked data or you want the
Semantic Web so we've got resources in
this graph like experiments and
measurements and documents and they're
all linked together and there are
scientists thrown in for good measure
because apparently they do the work but
this isn't always achievable and the
reason for this is the provenance
provenance is the lineage or the
pedigree of the data gives you an
impression as to why that data might
exist it gives you the context that
allows you to interpret that data and
this Carol goble said in her musings on
provenance there are seven w's or six wh
depending on how you look at it I've
tried to arrange these things in a nice
little pyramid structure so what we've
got is the who so the authors this is
very important and we've also got this
notion of the enactment so what and how
and these things are very common placed
on the internet you will find people
publishing provenance about you know who
done it and what they've done
unfortunately things are missing
typically the annotations so where they
did the work when they did the work
timestamps are incredibly important but
often missing and the biggest one that's
that often ignored as I put here is the
why the plan so why does the data exists
this is a critical question that we'd
like to ask but we can't answer at the
moment so enter the oricon project
funded generously by Microsoft Research
and the goal of the project is to
investigate what infrastructure would
need to be put in place in order to
enable the people to answer ask these
questions about the why so I've tried to
just label this diagram with the
relevant ontology s so re chem is going
to describe the planning and enactment
so why the data exists what data is
there and then we're going to use other
ontology to talk about authorship and to
do annotations so just as a few examples
we've got dublin core friend of a friend
geonames for describing the geolocation
of data owl time the timestamps and for
time spans which is increasingly
important so now I'm just going to give
a quick introduction to the ontology
this is a UML class diagram that
describes the re chem core ontology so
the idea is that the ontology
distinguishes between two types of thing
a planned thing and a run thing a
planned thing is something that is going
to be realized in the future so you plan
something and then you enact that thing
that you've just planned and the run
thing is a kind of retrospective
description I've just done this so what
we've got is the plan things is the plan
which acts as a nice container it's a
document we can get a URI for it we can
share the links and people can look at
my plans and maybe we'll integrate that
with my experiment one day and then we
have the runs at the bottom and as I
said a run is this realized version of a
plan and I'm going to talk about
realization in a bit so planning as I've
said is a prospective provenance it's
things that will be enacted in the
future it's data that will come into
existence what we're doing is describing
the requirements for our experiment so
I've got a small example here for
measuring the pH of a specimen of a
substance that's in a solution so the
idea is that we break down this workflow
or protocol or methodology or whatever
nomenclature you'd like to use into a
series of smaller stages and each stage
can have as input or output these data
products which are descriptions of
things that may be digital or might
exist in the real
so here we've got three objects at the
bottom one representing a vial of a
solution that will exist one
representing a sample of the solution
and as you can see we've got at the top
this takes sample box that requires the
big beaker and gives out as an output or
emits a small test tube of the solution
and then we've got another one for a
measurement and it says well in the
future we're going to have a pH value
and the benefit of doing this is that we
can describe each small resource we can
say well what is a pH value well it's
this term in that ontology and that
these kind of requirements are very
useful to capture and to share if I gave
this to a scientist and with the
relevant tools which I get onto in a bit
and they can fully understand what I
mean when I'm talking about measuring
the pH of some specimen so the enactment
is your retrospective provenance so once
we've described what we're going to do
we can now describe what we've done and
so what we've got now are two stages
I've just called them s0 and s1 so you
can tell I'm a computer scientist
because I start at zero and we've got
some descriptions of a real beaker that
now exists a real test tube of a
specimen that now exists and the value
it turns out we were measuring the pH of
pure water great so one of the things
you might notice are the dashed lines
between the different boxes and these
are causal relationships which we can
infer from the relationships between the
stages and the objects so two examples
of the causal relationships are the
followed relationship which says that
this stage had to have occurred after
that stage it's quite easy to infer
because if you look at s0 and s1 the
output of s0 has been used by s1 the
other causal relationship that we have
is called derived from and that's to
indicate that the input so the example
s0 the inputs have had some effect on
the outputs and so it's possible to
create a chain of provenance assertions
and we can work our way back from the
data value
all the way back to the sambal all the
way back to you know the bucket but we
took the sample from but there's an
issue and this quote it's always
attributed to Yogi Berra but them I
can't actually find the proper citation
for it so I'm just going to say unknown
in theory there's no difference between
theory and practice but in practice
there is and that this is especially
true in science you you never do what
you say you're going to do unfortunately
we live in the owl universe so
everything is the Semantic Web and the
problem with not doing what you say
you're going to do is that the
assertions that you make often turn out
to be inconsistent so if you've ever
used the property editor everything just
turns red and it's very frustrating so
what we wanted to do is instead of
having this notion of instantiation
which is where you say well let's say I
have a car class I then have an instance
of the car that's very good until you
might change your plan and use a
different car what we have instead is
realization we're saying well I'm going
to describe a car that's yet to exist
and i'm going to describe a car that
does actually exist in reality and i'm
going to link the two together the main
advantage of doing that is that you can
deviate from the plan and the protege
and all other el reason there's won't
grumble at you so what we've got here
are the two diagrams describing the
measurement of a ph and we're showing
the links from the realizations back to
the plan so it's very clear I hope it's
very clear that you can follow each
individual data product back to the
methodology that was the reason why it
exists okay so time for a case study in
x-ray crystallography and so I just
thought I'd introduced the current
practice in x-ray crystallography the
data that is produced is very very
highly structured it's a great field for
producing data they know exactly what
they want their files to say and there
are very good standards to save these
things the de facto standard is called
the crystallographic information file or
the SIF file and there was a recent
report
list by disk or a body in the UK and
they actually they were really very keen
to promote the set file in
crystallography and there's a whole
section of this report dedicated to the
use of sips which is quite good the only
problem there is that relatively few
crystal structures or SIF files are
openly available so this is a one of the
main drawbacks to not having openly
available data is that you have the
possibility for fraud there have been
some very highly publicized cases the
one on the right is particularly
relevant mr. Murphy decided to publish
structures that were unfeasible and
couldn't actually be reproduced by the
review panel the only problem there was
that because he didn't publish his raw
data and because no one bothered to
check or ask for you know his raw data
people were citing him and in the end
there are about 200 derivative works
which have all been invalidated now
purely because there was broad
discovered at the root so if we could
provide an ontology or any other
mechanism that could create these causal
relationships and allow people to search
them then fraud could be detected
earlier and all of this horrible
situation could be avoided so enter the
crystals Federation which is another
disk project and the goal of the project
is to create a network of
crystallography resources the great
thing about eat crystals is all of the
published records and i want to
emphasize published so records can be
embargoed and often are but as soon as
the record becomes public and openly
available all the data is made available
as open data and open data is in capital
letters because there are certain
requirements that are mandated for you
to have the open data badge of here on
your website one of them is that all of
the data files must be persisted over
time and this is incredibly important
it's also important to note that a
crystal ziz based on ePrint which is
great software because it's extensible
and I'll talk more about that in a
second so just to give you an example of
Annie crystals record each record has a
lot of
the data is highly structured there's
bibliographic metadata so the authorship
and the when so lots of time stamps
there's the fundamental and derived data
and the idea there is that everything is
provided so that you can perform your
own validation and verification of the
final result and of course I've got
there the final structure solution is
also provided and if you can see on the
screen shot I know it's a bit small
sorry about that bitter there's actually
a j mol rendering of the SIF file that
is produced as the final solution so how
did they actually get there bear in mind
I'm not a chemist or a crystallographer
this is a very high level description of
what they're doing they take a powder
specimen of a substance they bombard it
with x-rays they measure the angles for
the diffraction so X ray hits the
structure and bounces off somewhere they
compute the electron densities and then
buy some serendipity and the guy called
Pete in the case of e crystals are they
arrive at a crystal structure solution
the diagram though on the right of the
slide is taken from the original ikura
stals paper so this is actually quite
important they did have an idea of what
their workflow actually was after a lot
of consultation it turns out that what
they thought they were doing and what
they were actually doing with two very
different things so what we did is via a
rican project is we decided to construct
a plan or an o re chem plan to describe
their methodology and as I said before
the plan contains the requirements in
this case it's the requirements for the
software and the data products that are
produced so we've got they use many
specialists applications and data files
and the plan allows you to say use this
application to turn that file into this
one and it goes on and on and on and
what we end up with is a very nice
causal relationships running down the
diagram and so we can see oh they're
going to start with some raw data and
they're going to end up with a fully
finalised structure solution so each of
these is then turned into an oem run so
a run is a description of a realization
of a plan in this case for e chris
each crystal each record in the
repository is turned into an array
kamrun document that's RDF XML what
you're looking at in the diagram is
actually using XSL to turn that document
into something that looks more like a
web page we have found that the clients
eat crystals don't like looking at RDF
data they must prefer HTML and tables we
use swirl the Semantic Web rule language
to infer the causal relationships and
this run describes the software that was
used and the data files that were
produced and this is really important
and the diagram actually that's shown in
the India slide we found that the e
crystals clients are very appreciative
that when we give them these diagrams
they know exactly what files have been
produced and how so how do we actually
arrived at these diagrams what we've got
to start off with we have the full this
is on the left i should say we have the
full breakdown of the run so there's
stages which are the rectangles and
objects which are the ellipses the
stages represent software applications
the ellipses the data product and we've
got two relationships stone with solid
and dashed edges so the vast ones are
the used relationship or has as input
and the solid arrows are emitted or has
as output and then we do a bit of swirl
on this in order to arrive at be a
diagram on the right so now that I've
told you that you can probably see how
it works but for those who can't let
show you the swirl real quickly so what
we're saying in the swirl rule is if a
stage uses an object and emits another
object then there's got to be some
causal relationship between those two
objects and so just as an example here's
X prep which is an application that they
use and what we're going to do is apply
the swirl rule and we get this nice
causal relationship so we can say that
the files are derived from each other
and the derived from tree is actually
placed on the e crystals website and
customers don't really care what
software is used they just want to know
what files are available
this is just an interesting outcome so
what kind of things can we do now and
this was going back to the
crystallography and fraud idea well we
can start doing SPARQL queries we can
start asking intelligent questions I
realized sparql isn't very exciting to
read so here's the pictorial version
what we're doing with this query is
we're asking for get me the raw data the
reported result and everything in
between and the nice thing about using
re chem is that we can essentially link
our query to the methodology to the plan
we can say well the raw data is the
realization of in this case and hkl file
an hkl file if anyone seen the front
cover of godel escher back you've got
the HK and L dimensions and that's
basically it thus if file is the
crystallographic information file and
they're both contained in this ich
restores plan and so the result of this
query is so just for the example record
a crystal 20 we have the re can run
we've got the raw data we've got the
reported result and we have everything
in between so this is incredibly
powerful because now for every record we
can say well here are all the data
products that you the review panel need
to look at in order to verify and
validate this work so just to show you
everything all together this would be
the result if you executed the SPARQL
query these are the bindings that you'd
get back so there are three results and
that would make three rows or three sets
of bindings in the SPARQL result ok so
just to summarize and give you an idea
of the future work we want to expand on
the core ontology one of the things that
we haven't looked at yet is the notion
of branching and conditional structures
so it is possible that you'll want to
ask the in actor a question you know in
a hypothetical sense and say you know
which path in the methodology should I
follow given everything that I've
already done and the other idea that we
want to pursue is something called
continuations this is particularly
important how does one represent a set
of data points steve is smiling over
there
Steve laser experiment produces
thousands of data points and rdf even if
you're using the very very compact see
realizations of rdf it becomes
incredibly cumbersome to talk about
thousands of things in the same document
we've practiced many a web browser so
what we want to be able to do is
describe a continuation we want to say
we have this set of points we have the
set of timestamps you glue them together
for me so that it doesn't crash my
browser the next thing that we want to
do is have a lower ontology that can be
specialized for physical and
computational chemistry so you can bring
in terms like software application
script relationships between them and
specialist resources for chemistry like
a sample or a specimen and finally we
want to talk about or we want to
implement applications and services that
use re chem so some of the ideas that
we've been discussing is having a
designer application for the plans so
that people have this nice graphical
interface that they can work in and then
the idea of an in actor or a way of
simply ingesting the plan and providing
the scientist with some kind of
interface where they can say what
they've done and this is really
important because I've said previously
you don't always do what you say you're
going to do and lots of tools that have
been produced won't name any names
suffer from the issue where if you
deviate from the plan the tool breaks
because it's simply incapable of doing
something that wasn't previously
accounted for and the last thing that we
want to do is have a provenance
inspector so once you've enacted your
plan you want to review the results you
might want to compile the paper to talk
about that or maybe you want to send
that provenance information to someone
else so to summarize here's the summary
expressed in XML and their displays do a
few acknowledgments so thank you very
much to microsoft research for funding
the project and i've tried to get all
the names of project members on there
but i'm sure i've probably missed a few
people so the oricon project the pi/4
the project is called egusi from Cornell
Southampton are involved obviously we've
been working with Cambridge we've been
working with Penn State University with
the lead yalls group and
though with Indiana University
University of Indiana with Marlon
Pierce's group so thank you very much
and you happy to answer any questions
thank you very much mark does fantastic
causes me to wonder if we had a plan for
the re chem project we should have maybe
we should do insist on for all of our
future rug so your sparkle slide went by
very quickly I didn't quite follow it so
you need to somehow compute a transitive
closure or something yeah in order to
get all the information you wanted there
how do you do that in sparkle is there a
recursion capability there or or using
property paths in sparkle 11 or what are
you doing how we at the moment we're
actually implementing the queries we've
got some a handcrafted libraries there
is a lot of scope for optimization
though once we get access to the query
engine it is possible to bounce the
queries by these realization
relationships between the runs and the
plans I'm just going to plug my laptop
and again so I can okay so that there
are facilities coming in sparkle 11 I
know for property paths that allow
regular expression on paths which looked
like they would be useful for Providence
but I'm not quite sure how you do it in
the current incarnation of sparkle like
I said at the moment we are implementing
these things by hand it is very very
expensive to do transitive closures in
fact we actually have to use two of them
in order to do the query that I showed
on the slides right here we go and so
at the moment we are using dig and a
combination of dig and pellet to do bar
queries so I'm just going to bring it up
on the screen so the red arrows or the
has plan object relationships are used
to bound the query in order to make the
transitive closure is a little more
efficient to compute time for one more
question you go you want to come up
thank you very much let's give mark
another pan and the connection there you
go second speaker in the session this
morning is Hugo hidin from Newcastle
University who's going to be talking on
accelerating chemical property
prediction with cloud computing
furnishing us with the cloud in the
session title this whole excuse me
second let's get this
I thought these are supposed to just
work right um what I'm going to talk
about is some work we did earlier this
year with some people in the Cancer
Research Institute in Newcastle
University and what we were doing is
trying to make use of cloud computing
windows azure to speed up the process of
building predictive models of chemicals
it was funded by Microsoft to generously
providers with these euro resource and
also some of the salaries I was involved
with the implementation side in
computing science I was very much led
technically by the Institute for cancer
research who suggested this something we
might like to do and sort of really
guide is with the science behind it
fundamentally what they're trying to do
is given a molecule or a structure it's
trying to work out how it's likely to
perform so in terms of drug discovery
how toxic is it how soluble is it going
to be how active it's going to be
against what you're interested in
understanding way of doing that supposed
to get a sample of this take it to a lab
and actually do the experiments but when
you've got thousands of things you want
to screen which are very expensive to
buy if you can buy them at all that's a
difficult process and also be doing
things like toxicity you want to
minimize the number of experiments you
do because systems of ethical
constraints in there as well so what
they do is use a technology called qsar
or quantitative structure-activity
relationship and what that says is the
properties of your molecule are somehow
related to the shape of it all the
structure its attributes like the length
of it or the number of certain types of
atoms or whatever usually in terms of
numerical things you can work out for a
structure you can use that to relate
that to the properties we look recently
there's sort of three thousand things
about you can measure or work out for a
particular structure so there's lots of
information you can take about this and
use that to relate that to the
properties that you're interested in
there's a lot of data around as well to
help me do that we use three databases
Campbell one button on bat PK
pharmacokinetic database
camera one for example has 600,000
compounds and it was actually taken from
34,000 publications that set of students
in East Europe I believe will pay to
just type in these things into databases
one but PK there's lots of clinical
measurements in there as well which is
very useful and in the database what
we're interested is its structure
information so the shape of these things
and the numerical activity values so the
problem becomes what's relationship
between those two things how do you rate
structure to the activity q ser is
really just a regression exercise really
it goes through the standard process
where you take the data you build your
models you'll validate them on unseen
data and then you use those models to
predict instructors you haven't seen
before so what you do to build a set
these models it's picked compound list
similar to what you're interested in you
select from those three thousand
predictors ones you want to calculate so
you'll work all those out because you've
taken the data from one of these
databases you actually know what the
activities really were so that gives you
a set of X data and set a wide data in
terms of modeling and then you can
relate those two things together the
problems are or which compounds you pick
to build the models on of those 3,000
descriptors what you want to calculate
and also there's any number of different
modeling techniques you can use so which
one do you actually want to have a look
at so given a model the next set is to
actually see how that works on day two
it wasn't trained on so you'll pick
another set of compounds again probably
similar calculate the same set
descriptors and use that model to give
you an estimate other thing you're
interested in again you know the actual
so then you can work out what your error
was so then if that models acceptable
you can then use that with structures
you haven't seen before to give an
estimate of the properties you're
interested in so what they do in
Newcastle is to screen big libraries of
compounds using these things to try and
pick out ones that are worth
investigating further so they use these
models and sort of screen thousands and
say all these thousands these ones are
the ones I'm going to look at and what
we do with a junior project
is to try and model all the data we
could find and make it available on a
website it's called open qsar com it may
or may not be running at the moment hope
to do it later but we'll see the problem
with this Q star process is that there's
a lot of choices you have to make all
the way through it so which descriptors
you're going to pick what model you want
to build how you're going to test them
and the quality of the models you get
really depends on getting these choices
right but it's always different so
different properties will have different
models that predict them well I'd say
the junior project aim to model all the
public data we could find but we use a
system that the Cancer Research people
had called discovery bus and all that
does is it applies old modeling
techniques you show it to all the data
so it's a huge system that tracks the
process of building these balls so to
discuss this of it the standard process
after that you get training test data
calculate descriptors and build the
model but with all the choices you have
there's different ways of splitting the
data there's different descriptor
calculators you can use how you pick
those is also an open question so
there's lots of different ways of
selecting which ones are going to use
and then the different model things
models you use so you get a lot of
information that needs to be managed in
the process of building these models and
discovery bus sort of coordinates all of
this it's an old system it's big balance
since the late 90s it was built with
Oracle it uses stored procedures to do
most of its logic it's horrible to
maintain and look at models built in our
which is an open-source statistical
language we also do some models in Java
and the system's meant to scale by
having multiple agents that can do this
modeling work one of the attributes the
disturbances it's always active so once
you started off modeling process is
never truly finished because if you add
a new set of data to it and you
descriptor calculator or a new model
it'll go back and update the results for
that new data so it's always sitting
there running the idea behind it was to
connect it to sort of companies
it's a compound database then every time
you add more data to it with
automatically rebuild models as I say
it's very hard to maintain there's no
documentation to speak of and it's very
specific in what operating systems and
libraries it uses so we've managed to
get it running on ours and using a
specific version of Center just about
sits there running now so what we want
to do to extend that is to make use of
windows as you ought to provide more
resources to that also add different
types of agents different modeling
routines and try and move it towards and
it's more mental in a little bit more
modern and said that it does a lot of
useful stuff so this is the workflow
discovery boss uses when it builds a
model it's quite hard to see but there's
two steps your discovery model building
and validation that breaks down into
different parts as well so it's a
multi-level plan there's a lot of bits
of information that passed around and
cracked so it's not something we want to
really implement again we can get away
with it when we extend it pull around
something called a bus master which is
one machine that coordinate all the
whole process so this sort later and
that's the Oracle database there other
machines connect to this and
occasionally I'll sort of the query this
is there anything needs to be calculated
so there forever polling this master
pulling out work to do there's another
agent which continuously looks at all
the models you have all the data sets
and works out if there's anything that
needs to be done and what we did is sort
of fake one of these agents we called a
proxy agent it looks to discovery bus
like everything else but what it does is
it sends the work that he does out to
our working roles in Windows Azure and
we scale by having that proxy agent
pretend to be lots of agents so our
initial results first up with two
workers so two of those proxy agents did
our set of data in just over an hour
again up to ten we've gotta speed up so
what you see here is a sort of
computational intensive bit where you're
building these descriptors in
calculating the models and then it goes
on to a kind of admin and validation
stage
so 20 workers so it squeezes up our cave
in a bit of it we still have that same
tail at the end and that was our problem
really which only really scale as far as
20 workers which isn't very good the
problem is really that this huge great
tail on the end of it after you done the
computation expensive bit where it's
validating and checking models doesn't
scale very well because they each its
focus on the database aspect of things
so a lot of that is based on Oracle
stored procedures which don't go out to
a zero at all so it gives this huge long
tail that we don't get any further with
making it better so after a lot of
testing it basically comes down to the
fact that it's all built around one
databases a single point in the middle
that everything has to go through so the
obvious thing we did was try and try and
optimize that it was running originally
under standard amazon vm so we bought
the biggest fastest machine we could get
for it the data was stored what's called
an EBS a block store which is
effectively a network drive so we moved
that on to the node itself which helped
us we use of standard things at NFS to
move files around cuz it was using a
single threaded file transfer which
didn't help and also trying to optimize
the store procedure something we really
didn't want to have to do so I got it
down to taking about second for it to
work out there was some new job that
needed to do which gave us a kind of
limit really we couldn't generate models
more than one a second so that's as fast
as our system could go and that's really
the limitation discovery bus being
always active and always doing a lot of
work in the background to work out
what's need to be done next so we do
things like trying to simplify the
models plans everything and we got down
to scans about 250 nodes and this is the
result of that before out simulation we
had that biker CPU and then the long
tail so that's nineteen as you are nodes
taking two and a half hours afterwards
one and a half hours in about 15 so
we've got much better utilization
probably as good as we're going to get
with this
so having done that we went ahead and
built on the models and put them on a
juicer and I'll try and show you that
now so this is the site if you look at
the property so fingers crossed these
are all the property modeled the type of
thing here so I see 50 is a measure of
how how well it actually works against
something so this from the bottom we've
got 25 models so I go into one of those
of those information about its training
performance is testing performance we
will be able to get predictions can't
yet so you'll be able to paste in as
structural set of structures and have it
actually give you the estimated
properties from that doesn't work yet
unfortunately but if you look at one of
these models this is it performance on
the training data and the testing data
there and also the descriptors are
actually picked for that model two out
of the thousands it's picked those of
ten scripts or so there so that's a site
with building at the moment we've got
sort of 205 240,000 models on there it's
an open coos I com although that address
doesn't look like that at the moment and
it's going to avail for people to get
predictions and hopefully download that
data as well and use it in other places
so
having done that we are we went back and
tried to analyze how poorly at scaled so
we run tests on zuv to 5 10 20 nodes and
what we try to do is compare the numbers
of models we go out per minute so each
data set we put in will generate about
80 models and they're called responses
so in discovery bus terminology so we
just try to do a graph of throughput
against system size it was expensive to
do because we've come to the point where
we weren't getting as your nose for free
anymore so we have to pay for all of
those so he only did it once so we
didn't do multiple runs of each so we
did one at 21 at five I'd like to see in
your half a dozen it to to see the kind
of spread of speed he got certainly
found that we get a lot of variability
and how things work depending on what
time you run it on and how busy other
machines were so we didn't get the best
it's a process for a benchmarking it but
this is what we found is that initially
it scales fairly well and as we hit the
lemon to the database at about 40 worker
nodes it just sort of dies then and in a
conference where people are talking in
terabytes and petabytes and gigabytes
and that the nodes to come on give the
number 40 s a bit embarrassing but there
you go it's what you get when you just
dump something naively on the cloud
really which comes to what we want to do
next we've got it running on the cloud
but we really didn't make use of a lot
of the components that are there the
would have probably helped us so if we
made use of queues blob storage and
table storage instead of the sequel
database we can probably get a lot
better so utilization of resources and
really try and move all the coordination
away from our central database and
distribute some of the coordination
around the components and the workflow
so once you've done something like
descriptors using a step in the workflow
that part will be responsible for
kicking off the next part so you move
logic out of the database onto the
queues and sort of distribute it around
and just use a database of storing
results at the end of it
I'm involved in a European project Venus
see also with Microsoft on what us
trying to do is put so a generic
interface on different clouds so what we
want to do and we're one of the use
cases in that is to make use of our time
to actually try and re implement the
discovery to make use of this API and
see if we can scale above sort of 40 and
50 nodes so to sum up moving it to the
cloud really exposes weaknesses in your
architecture I mean we didn't do that
well we're sort of dumping 100 times
additional resource onto the system so
we're going to need to change our
architecture to go further and I'm sure
that's the case in the lot of situations
where you know you just put it there and
it exposes problems straightaway but we
have generate a lot of models and
they're available people to use and
we've been able to take this resource
use it and switch it off so you know it
was it was very useful I did what it's
supposed to do and we can easily switch
it back on again and do it again and we
only really pay for four weeks of
computer time so it wasn't bad at all
and it should be the ideal cloud
application that it's bursty because
once you get settled 80 you need to do a
lot of work it's very used to paralyze
because all those models are independent
so you can just run them separately so
who are two up here well I Jeremy go for
us I was just curious so your peak at 40
yes was that due to the the problems of
the actual database yes we just hit
hundred percent CP on the database we
had the biggest serve as a machine we
could have with multiple CPUs and we
couldn't physically run it in a bigger
machine so that was just down to the you
know once we had that much data in there
the queries slow down just got bogged
down really unfortunately so it given
our architecture that's probably as far
as it'll go okay and that was the same
on as your you yeah I mean look the
original graph that the proxies were all
running in amazon so it looked to the
database as if there were just more
amazon resource so it wasn't a
communication to as your case file size
of UK
I don't think it's the difference
between the two clouds I think it's just
the architectural database once it was
in as you it was that so quick the real
difficulties in doing the modeling it's
choosing the data choosing your sets
yeah one of the dangers of letting it
just keep running is that effectively
the test set becomes part of the design
set I'm sure the ends up learning ice
yeah so it's all so I'm not quite clear
what's the automatic thing is something
particular test set oh I've got this
data yeah I mean he does he does it
decide on model it's going to do I me
not number so I'm not modeling what
actual problem is trying to be solved
it's one of the things you tell at the
beginning so you'll give it a data set
say I'm trying to model this property
with these things and it will go and
apply all the models it'll do so leave
on our validation and do so sensible
partition your data but it's basically a
sledgehammer the disk isn't smashes away
at it and for worse results and autism
so you can pick them so it doesn't have
any intelligence really okay so and then
if you come on so you just basically
keep I mean onset I've got a new problem
here yes this gives you all the options
back okay yeah and it'll sort them all
rank them in terms of you know
correlations and things that you want so
one of my concerns really it's I'd
forgotten that this the basic system was
there for so long but obviously you've
gotta have the computer power to run all
these things yeah so it runs and all the
data's comes back and it looks like a
black box to the users yeah now
currently most of the people build those
models have to know really quite a lot
about models Yahoo not get trapped is
there a the black box danger of internal
it is it's not popular with people if
your CUSO because it kind of takes away
some of the black magic of it but it's
like any black box need to interpret it
and be careful how you use it you might
backgrounds in chemical engineering and
modeling chemical processes on a larger
scale but once you've got a model you
gotta be careful to use it in the range
you trained it on and be very aware that
it doesn't extrapolate well and so same
problems there as well it just gives you
that range that you can pick things from
other questions for you go I
gratification I was just um essentially
you're just hitting Amdahl's law with
the paralyzation oh yeah because your
databases is yeah fundamentally
sequential process and therefore you're
always going to limit your scalability
so the only thing to do is to Tory
architect yeah which is the pain but
well it is but its opportunities and
we've got this kind of a couple years
project to do it we may as well tackle
it and see what we do yeah yes it's
going to be the same problem however we
have a centralized resource down the
middle we're going to get that
contention so unless we distribute it
yeah we're going to hit a limit soon
we'd like anyway yeah cuz I think I'd
forget in terms of patterns and
practices for cloud computing that's a
lesson that people who aren't
experienced in hpc you might yeah so
forget you hit really quickly and yeah
disappointing this yes it's good it
could use that in teaching parallel
computing I think it's an example here
any other questions open q sir calm yeah
I know it doesn't yes I don't know
what's wrong with its on amazon so it
might have the wrong IP address set of
it yes I gotta pay your bill on your
domain name registers very beside
yeah we are going to point out to him
that it's quite embarrassing and hope it
does it very soon but yeah it will be
there definitely all right it's not it
really isn't you could have been so much
worse but it's time for for lunch let's
give a final round of applause about
Mark Antony girls for babies